what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
Rob Petros o is the co-founder of rally
Road one of the hottest startups and
technology at the moment in this
conversation we discussed where the
original idea came from how the company
navigated the regulatory landscape to
empower fractional ownership of unique
assets what the process for selecting
assets looks like and where potential
intersections with Bitcoin and
blockchain may exist in the future I
really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you do as well skirt school 1 I
know who has the best URL crypto com
that's right
crypto comm there crypto platform with
one goal motherf and mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet career.com
is helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sends you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right if you
purchase it it shows up at your doorstep
you pull it out of the box you plug it
in connect to your Wi-Fi five minutes or
less you're mining Bitcoin all you have
to do is control it from the mobile app
they provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom
Sencha and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or
there at block five and receive 6%
annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly high
rate it's the best rate in the industry
I highly suggest you go check out block
Viacom / pop again that's blocked by
calm / pop to sign up and start earning
crypto today Anthony Pompano is a
partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I got Robin here
super excited to have this conversation
he is not in the crypto industry but
they're doing a lot of things that are
very tangentially related so well thanks
so much for coming to do this thank you
for having me much appreciate it
alright before we get to rally road
let's talk about what you did previously
because you you have kind of a unique
background where where you want to start
yes I'll start um I'll start in the
beginning so 20 call early 2000 2003
2004 I got at a school I went to school
for design I've always been a designer
when I got out of school it was this new
it was like web 2.0 a lot was happening
in the digital space where everybody
similar way crypto is now everybody's
trying to jump on this bandwagon
of what will be digital they don't know
what it is yet it's post-2000 collapse
everything is brand new so I'm doing as
much work as possible I wound up in the
music industry so I was working for a
bunch a bunch of new art is developing
brands and developing their web presence
and some little BOTS around what they
were doing for like promoting video and
radio and all these little elements that
everything self-taught everybody trying
something new it led to a bunch of
awesome opportunities in the startup
space so 2007-2008 comes around and the
iPhone comes out and kind of changed
everything dramatically and then the App
Store came out and changes everything
again where everybody that was even
thinking design first had to become this
user experience designer and had to
create product around the iPhone so why
don't they put a company called scroll
motion which is a digital publishing
suite that was creating content and
bringing things to life like big banks
and pharmaceutical companies and
traveling all over the world trying to
understand content and bring it to life
to a bunch of other great opportunities
so on the bed a company called Keamy
which is a computer vision play digital
locksmith here in New York and then at a
workplace company called convened for a
little while
built out some internal software a bunch
of hedge funds in between worked a
little bit citigroup work with ares
management so people that were really
kind of marrying the idea of finance and
design into this product that was for
you know this very unique end-user
whether it was employees or users with
regular banking no matter what it was
always as mix of design and finance and
it kind of eventually led to a
conversation with my current co-founders
Max and Chris I've known for a long time
about what the future of finance would
look like in like 2013-2014 and then led
to rally wrote down it and so what was
in those early conversations what did
you guys kind of identify as hey this is
the future that may not be here yet but
we think it's going in this direction
what was kind of the more macro or
structural things yeah so I mean it was
it was unavoidable so 2015 2016 when we
really started putting pen to paper on
this and the idea was invest in
alternative assets but do it at retail
so this is post you know oh wait oh nine
when myself and everyone around me lost
every dollar and it was something where
it was new and the only interface was
you know I had a TD Ameritrade account
and a coin based in exist and Robin Hood
didn't exist yet and you realize that
there's a very small group of people who
are making all the money at the exact
same time and they're waiting for bag
holders like me to give up in 2009 I
gave up and we started talking about
what the future look like for the stuff
that really sustained during that
downturn and that was you know gold had
its run but they're also tangible assets
that you know the the super wealthy had
access to and they were holding on to so
the last thing that something worth a
ton of money sells when things go bad is
the stuff they really care about
so for us we looked at things like
classic cars and watches and wine
collections and these things that were
really about collectibles and turning
those into something that you can invest
in was pretty obvious and then once you
know you start seeing all these other
players pop up you see the Robin Hood's
of the world that are activating this
huge uninvested population of people who
really start to get it they're younger
but they understand option strategies
they understand crypto they understand
these things that are really sort of
left field when it comes to the regular
investor and they're doing it at a
meaningful way they're doing it with you
know bigger account balances and they're
doing it where you know they understand
what earnings reports look like they
understand what eBay dies and they're 18
19 20 years old stuff I never understood
it became obvious that if we created
interface that work the same way as some
of these other products where you shrink
it down to a binary yes/no option with
some really unique education and do it
where it's these alternative assets that
everyone knows have value that we can do
something really really unique and
that's kind of what lets the
conversation about let's put let's make
this a very real thing yeah and so when
you guys first get started what was kind
of the initial product what are you guys
trying to build and kind of how did you
go from okay we got this idea let's you
know make the jump to that that initial
product he gave out to users yeah so
Chris our CEO my co-founder someone went
to high school with he um he's always
kind of understood the classic car space
which was the first asset class that we
started with and he made a decision a
long time ago he was gonna buy a he had
money neither buy like a house or to buy
this car this this Porsche that he
really really wanted and I talked to his
parents about it and like they knew the
right decision was to buy the house real
estate is a great investment it's
something that everyone knows you not to
educate anybody on so we bought the
house so now you know 15 years later the
house is around flat and the car he was
looking at as 10x since then so we
started thinking about like alright
there's a lot of asset classes like this
but the classic car space is one that we
kind of understand from a design
standpoint I always loved that I
understood that it was something that
found its way into a lot of other design
sort of practices whether it was fashion
or like sneakers and architecture the
lines of classic cars the things that go
with it always really important in the
design aspect but from a financial
perspective it was something that has
gone up into the right for a long time
and outpaced a bunch of of other indexes
so we looked at it and said if we can
take this and turn it into a stock and
do it in a way that doesn't intimidate
an end-user this might actually work so
that let's just sort of try to figure
out the mechanics of it talking to our
legal team creating a demo so that it
actually looked and felt like we would
actually have and trying to explain it
not just to ourselves but to the people
around us who we're gonna seed this
project and the lawyers are gonna be a
part of it to package up something that
the SEC could review and completely
understand and that was like the first
year and a half of the business
basically yeah not fun in terms of
inside exactly building the product and
making it look beautiful etc it's a lot
of kind of behind the scenes stuff that
just really tedious and complex yeah for
sure and like and you probably know this
like the the way the SEC in the way that
lawyers who charge you know nine hundred
dollars
now look at things is they want to see
like printed on paper photocopies of
stuff they want to mark it up they want
to understand every aspect of what
you're doing from that macro perspective
from that business perspective before it
even becomes a product that any what
they consider unsophisticated investor
would potentially see we have to make
sure that we cross all the T's and dot
all the I so you know the first 18
months of building when it was the end
of 2015 in the 2016 was about getting
everybody ourselves included comfortable
with the concept of investing in a thing
that's not a stock in an app and that
was like the biggest process start to
finish for sure and so where are you
guys today right let's talk about how
does the actual product itself work and
then we can get into kind of how it's
going but but just mechanically how does
the actual experience work if I'm a
person who downloads the app in it yeah
when I get started so if you download
the app the first thing that you see is
a quick tour that explains what these
individual assets are so right now you
you know you download the rally Road app
you open it you see a bunch of cars you
see some baseball cards you see some
wines you see a bunch of these really
unique assets some more esoteric than
others but all of them have value and
then inside of each of these individual
portals what you see is a bunch of
charts that show comp prices of similar
vehicles or similar bottles of wine over
the course of 10 20 and 30 years you
read a quick story about it so we shrink
down you know the entire history of
something that's 40 or 50 years old
let's say like a Mickey Mantle 1952
Topps baseball card which has all this
this era of importance around it but
it's also got a really interesting story
about you know what bunch we're thrown
in the Atlantic Ocean and top so the
shores gonna be a hit and now it's one
of the most important baseball cars of
all time so we tell that story in a
quick little educational portal you have
all the charts in there so it looks and
feels like equity charts too you can see
what the price appreciation has done
over time we related back to pop culture
so we always have kind of quotes or
those sort of magazine type polls that
explain why it's important to the 25
year old today and not just in 1952 and
then we give the option to invest in
what we call an initial offering so as
the first time shares is being being
sort of presented to the end-user
and it's in a way where we price it
based on very similar dynamics of the
way a regular IPO would be priced with
comps in the space with a bunch of
expert opinion with our advisory board
sort of looking at all the details and
then we let you invest we have all the
details there their certificates of
authenticity all the sort of the
record of each individual assets they
can kind of go into the details we have
the whole SEC qualification document
which these are all done under reg a
plus so each one of these individual
assets is almost like its own company
but its own balance sheet its own cap
table and by you investing in that
initial offering you jump onto the cap
table for that individual asset just
like regular IPOs you kind of have a
cooling-off period
so once the entire asset is funded so in
this case that Mickey Mantle card it
actually went live last week is a
hundred thirty two thousand dollar
company Wow and you know that's not the
only asset inside of that company is it
don't make email sound like an SP be
almost similar yeah it's like it's like
Mickey Mantle LLC yeah and then inside
of that is a cap table now with 264
individual investors and it's one of
those investors as part of that company
so now for 90 days that's locked up
there's no training that happens and
then after that lockup period is done
every around thirty to sixty days you
open up what we call a trading window
which is all done through register
broker dealers where it's really
peer-to-peer and a way that you come in
we price it kind of like a Dutch auction
where there's one clearing price end of
day but for that one day a month you can
sort of bid or ask if you own shares to
buy or sell those individual shares so
not the way for an exit of the actual
asset to be able to exit your investment
it's almost like periodic liquidity in
before we before we go back to the
structure let's talk about this for a
second it says one of the things that I
noticed immediately is there's no
exchange right I think part of like
compared to the crypto world where it's
24/7 365 and liquidity all the time and
that's a huge benefit there's also some
drawbacks to it yeah what you guys are
doing here is you're providing once a
month let's call it right and there's
like kind of a 24-hour window or so one
what happens if I missed the window can
I set reminders all I stopped attending
to why go with that structure rather
than some kind of more continuous
liquidity type structure yeah it's the
right question I think that we looked at
it in a way that we want to sort of
build our community with a lot of
educated investors so when we think
about why we built this platform we
think about the platforms that we came
from that we really were birthed there
from which are the coin basis of the
world and the Robin Hood's of the world
we look at ourselves as one of those
four alternative assets the big
difference for us is that I think you
know in December of 2017 when you know
everybody is having the conversation
about Bitcoin right before this
precipitous drop
the continuous nature of that
marketplace I think and you might have a
different opinion this accelerated the
the way that that bottom fell out really
quickly and there was a lot of sort of
bag holders who were brand-new to it in
2017 who got left holding those you know
$17,000 coins and 16,000 coins and we
didn't want to be in a situation that we
did things it responsibly so for us it's
always been like a buildup and making
sure that everybody on our platform is
completely educated about the process
before we get to a point that were a
continuous market so what we did is we
do this sort of the once monthly once
every 60 days more more so than not to
really make everyone understand exactly
what's happening in that trading
component of the platform before we get
to a point that's continuous because a
lot of them are first-time investors a
lot of them - or almost all of them are
first-time alternative asset investors
and someone might you know have a piece
of real estate or might like have an old
baseball card or something that's not
the same as trading it so we want to
make sure that everybody understands
exactly how this thing works before we
get to a point that it's that
never-ending bid ask and we'll get there
at some point I think what we're we're
putting into the app right now is the
ability to sort of add your bid or add
your ask and build the book before the
execution date but we'll slowly start to
add more of those execution days to make
sure that everybody can get fill to this
point it's been a really responsible
marketplace we don't have a lot of ass
that don't get filled at times I'll have
bids that don't get filled but it's
something that people are always like I
really want to get on this but they also
want understand how it all works so it's
been very responsible to this point I
think we want to sort of maintain that
responsibility until we get to the point
that it's truly continuous yeah and how
do you go about selecting the assets
themselves right because to me that's
like a huge piece of this is obviously
you guys have built what I'll call kind
of a wrapper around the asset so you've
done a great job with the charts the
description the story the ability to
kind of see all of the the legal and
regulatory stuff you know and really
present all the information that I need
to make a decision on whether I want to
gain access to something or not but a
huge component that is like what am I
actually buying you right and so whether
it's a classic car it's a baseball card
etc like there's some pretty cool [ __ ]
right I can say that I don't know if you
can put there's like cool shouts a cool
[ __ ] I can't say I think about future
returns
alright there's definitely cool [ __ ] on
that it's so like how do you guys go
about sourcing this stuff vetting it you
know who makes the ultimate decision as
to what gets listed what doesn't get
listed and are there things that maybe
you like we're super excited about that
ended up not getting listed for you know
X Y or Z reason absolutely I mean when I
look at sort of what we're doing right
now it's always been like the coolship
factor is a huge part of it the idea
that there's the a very so like the
auction mark if we think about cars if
you want it to sort of sell a vehicle
and you had a great car no matter what
it is if it's a 60s era Ferrari let's
say you want to sell and you go it away
on one of these big auction houses no
matter what they're gonna make you sign
this agreement that says that the only
they have accessed this vehicle for six
months to a year let's say you're
probably gonna pay for some of the
marketing expenses in the travel you're
gonna be giving 20% either on one side
the other the buy or the sell side for
the privilege to sell that vehicle if
they're at an auction and it's a little
bit of a flat auction there's only a
hundred people in the room and nobody
wants your car they're gonna push you to
take the reserve off and sell it as
quickly as possible so all these
dynamics created this world that is very
very closed off right now and then for
the buyer you have to be in the room at
the right time you have to be on their
books are ready to buy it you gotta buy
the whole thing you gotta take it with
you when you leave there's all these
sort of barriers on both sides so we
looked at it as as we can get the best
possible assets and curate a great
collection because so many of these
people don't want to go that route
anymore that are selling the assets and
some of the buyers don't even know it
exists so if we can kind of create this
checklist which right now we have like
this 18 point checklist it has a little
bit of sort of algorithmic value to it
to where in the background we're always
figuring out the cultural relevance of
individual asset and we're trying to
figure out what the next three to four
years look like for that asset based on
upcoming auction so many insurance
values some of the data that we keep
in-house but there's also that that
manual curation part we keep the best
people around us in the space so when it
comes to cars you know we have a great
internal team that vets a lot of this
stuff for us right now and has those in
rows and has that network we also have a
great team of advisors around us but we
put on the books of our company to make
sure that we're always sourcing best
possible asset for garlis of whether I
like it or not as a person I might look
at something and say that's that's
amazing that's so cool but if it's at
the downtrend right now like we're not
gonna buy that vehicle that's something
that isn't gonna be going to market and
is gonna get attention the next three to
four years we're not gonna buy that
vehicle but it's also a situation that
will take a flyer on something we buy
opportunistically and we have some
intuition that we feel like this is the
right vehicle to buy because we
our investors in each of these assets as
well so up to 10% of the asset we buy at
the exact same price as investors off of
our books like we buy that with cash and
we can't sell so until the vehicle exits
we can't sell yeah so we oh we do
believe in these assets we want to make
sure we're getting best available we
want to curate the best possible
collection so that when you're when it's
time to sort of exit some of these
things if you want to find the best
version you have to come to us for this
yeah and I think it's a really big
pieces you guys were putting money where
your mouth is right like the things that
you show to your user base or your
investors are things that you're putting
your cash alongside so it kind of speaks
to where your conviction level is let's
talk about the cars for a second yeah
where are these cars are they sitting in
like a parking lot in the middle of
Manhattan and or somewhere in down the
block up 40 seconds great where you guys
keep it yes so we have we have a
purpose-built facility that we keep all
those vehicles and so the vehicles right
now we're all in one place we're trying
to find a place that makes it more
accessible to everybody so investors
always have a chance to see them which
we always make it available now but
right now you know we have one space in
Pennsylvania we have one in Connecticut
it's really about sort of keeping the
collection all in one place so we also
have a retail location that we just
opened in about seven months ago in Soho
that our is our first sort of iteration
of what will be the living museum so
right now there's a 1980s Aston Martin
in the middle of the store on Lafayette
Street between Prince and spring
surrounded by it or a bunch of cases
that have like the Mickey male cards
there there's an amazing Birkin bag
there there's all these elements that
are really unique that we want to put on
display that you can see and then sort
of leave with a piece of it any time we
could do that we'll always do that as of
right now the vehicle which is a fleet
of around 60 cars is in this
purpose-built facility 24-hour concierge
we have a camera feed that we're putting
into the app now too
but we want to make sure it's always
accessible so we'll be doing things to
really drive not just interest but we
want to drive dividends for our users as
well so that anytime we can put a car in
a hotel lobby or have an event inside of
our space and there's a car there that
you've invested in anytime we could
selling merch around these individual
vehicles or assets which we're starting
to do really effectively now that goes
into the bank account for that car or
for that asset and you get paid out a
special dividend as an investor for
owning it
got it and so in terms of the retail
location right down in
in Manhattan it's pretty cool when you
walk in you you you definitely feel like
hey this brand stands for something
different right and and I think that
there's kind of this element again of
the kind of cool [ __ ] going on yeah
uh-huh how do you decide what goes in
there how often do you switch that stuff
out yeah because I think that's a
different car then yeah weeks ago yeah
we do we try and do it like once we're
trying to down and akkadian stuff like
once a month where everything switches
out but what we really want to do is put
the marquee asset there so like we have
this ask some more in there now because
we made sort of the bet on that vehicle
about a year ago and we made the
acquisition it's gonna be in the new
Bond movie it's a very sort of a unique
story that goes along with it but it
also speaks what we're doing as a
company where it's like that 80s and 90s
sort of feel like we realized that a lot
of people that are coming into that
space they're around our age like
they're you know thirty year olds that
have an understanding of how the markets
work but they see something like this
and it has this brand resonance and we
can tell a great story around it so
anytime you have a marquee vehicle or a
marquee asset one that's gonna be in the
app available for investment soon I was
gonna be trading soon we make sure
there's a place for that in a really
unique space you can come in have a
conversation like that for us is our
it's our Investor Relations Center more
than anything else people walking off
the street from all walks of life and
they see this you know million dollar
car sitting in the middle and all these
things and they just say inevitably they
just wind up saying like what is this
and it becomes a really very
conversation those people stay in the
store for 20 or 30 minutes with their
whole family having the conversation and
then they leave understanding exactly
what we do so I Tommy can kind of tell a
great story anytime it's an asset that's
coming into the app soon anytime it's a
marquee vehicle or a marquee asset
that's you know gets edges close to that
million dollars we're gonna put you know
a million bucks in the middle of Soho
and have the conversation that's what
goes in that store that's our permanent
location our office is there too but now
we're talking to spin up a few pop-ups
all over the country to make sure that
you know new investors have access to
these really unique things as well - the
cool [ __ ] we want make sure everyone has
access to it you know for sure and I
guess what's the tangental relationship
to crypto right so a lot of the things
you guys are doing have elements right
and what I mean by that is there's a
crowdsourcing component right so you can
kind of look at it as a an investor base
that all comes together for one asset
there's fractional ownership of that
asset the way that the information is
being presented through the reggae Plus
there's kind of a a non-accredited
investors to this right just a lot of
either things that from an ethos
standpoint or close or actually
mechanically they look very similar
there's no tokens right there's no kind
of real crypto or blockchain component
today maybe talk through a little bit of
the pros and cons and kind of how you
guys have thought about this previously
will you go in that direction yeah yeah
I mean and it's you hit it right on the
head it's one of those things that
tangentially lives in a place where
people can relate it to a coin base or
to sort of what people with the
fractional ownership in the idea of not
owning that whole piece not having to
buy one individual unit and that's
always what we looked at as sort of like
the path of least resistance for us in
terms of getting and user to understand
what we're doing so when we think about
like what we're going to do as a company
we you know 2015 2016 is when we're
really having the conversation about
what the structure of the business would
look like and that was like peak
conversation peak of CEO and it was peak
you know it was peak crypto for a lot of
retail investors so we based so much
what we did and so much time was spent
without lawyers thinking about what a
tokenize offering will look like and
this was 2016 was a situation where the
difference between utility and security
was still very blurry at the time and we
were thinking like if we can do this in
a way where you know your your
investment is your ticket to the store
and we're trying to connect the dots and
we realized that after talking to our
lawyers and having the initial
conversation with the SEC we don't want
to go down a pathway that put us in the
crosshairs or anything went wrong and
sort of you know collateral damage like
that was what we always looked at as
sort of the the what we want to stay
away from so as much as I wanted to you
know all of us thinking about seeing all
these ICO is just print non delude of
capital and it was like could we do
something like this it's crazy we
couldn't not have the conversation
basically I know but we always knew that
like it's a blockchain element to this
and I think a lot of other companies
that are sneaking into the space right
now are thinking about in terms of
putting the assets on the blockchain and
having that you know that no third party
living in between you and the
information is the promise of
tokenization of an ass yeah and it's
going to happen I think we're gonna be
there at some point if and when we don't
know yet we do know that this is
definitely security like we're talking
with the how we test and things that
make this a real thing we have to go the
route that we're going right now it's
also a trust stamp for us sue there is a
lot of retail investing that happens
where you know they're just saying yes
it's something on coin base and they're
not necessarily understanding what the
dynamics of that investment look like
and what the the fees that go along with
it and what their
the fact that it's not pretended like
they don't have the keys their own
private keys to their individual invest
we want to make sure that everybody on
our platform understands what we're
doing that the trust stamp from the the
Reg A+ SEC qualified offering as part of
it as soon as we can get to a point that
socialization is a little bit more
understood where now it's still a
situation I feel like and your your
you're in it you're neck deep in this
I'm like needs even you know name so I
think about what this is in the future
and a lot of I don't know the people
that we talk to don't know to make a
decision to go around they get still
gets confused by a retail investor when
you think about a crypto blockchain
token all these individually get
confuses one thing with a lot of retail
investors and we have so many first-time
investors that to do with the SEC has
reggae Plus and think about tokenization
later it was always what we thought of
of the way to do this best but we'll get
there very very soon
skirts Co want to know who has the best
URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm their crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mine
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom sent
you and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent
interest paid monthly in cryptocurrency
this rate actually compound so you
receive a 6.2 percent a py which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pop again block
5 comm / pump to sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today
and I guess really the thought process
here for you is you can kind of take two
different approaches right so there's
one is go the unregulated route kind of
go very quick and then worry about the
repercussions later we've seen a lot of
people who did that not so much in the
tokenization of assets side but really
in building protocols except some of
them got really bad penalties and some
kind of slaps on the wrist all right so
so kind of a whole whole different
degree of penalties there but then the
other end of that spectrum is to go the
heavily regulated route right and so
what you guys have essentially done is
you've taken that ladder out but the
part that I like about this is if you
were to go to the tokenization in terms
of the blockchain you know component not
a lot would change I don't think for the
end user
absolutely not yeah yeah at this point
nothing will change don't think that was
a difference that you know the SEC they
really have an opinion on it when we
were first coming out so it was still
like do we go this route and hope for
the best and then it was like talking to
lawyers about incorporating the Cayman
Islands and stuff looks like we're going
around we don't even want to think about
right now you domain so we stayed away
from it but now it's it's front of mine
when people have the conversation at
least there's something to understand
exactly what you're saying what that
means I think for us going the heavily
regulated route I think is a must for
the for the near term for sure we want
to stay in that route we feel like we
have a good relationship with the SEC
right now and the process works and
people understand it the the sooner we
can go that that blockchain route
without changing any dynamics for the
end-user is one will pull that trigger
basically for sure I think you hit it
right on the head got it and today it's
open to us investors international and
US investors only and we're working
quick to go international it's there's
much more of a regulatory thing yeah
it's one of those things where like the
way the SEC works now is that to go
state by state is different than going
region by region once you go overseas
they all have their own rules don't
regulation that goes with it and you go
into
country doesn't necessarily mean you go
into another country in the EU even so
the quicker we can get there we will I
think right now we better really a
unique and super interested user base
who loves what we're doing they're hyper
engaged you know we have better metrics
and I think a lot of the other sort of
FinTech platforms for sure based on what
we know and we want to continue to sort
of support those investors as best we
possibly can before we make the leap to
go international talk to me about the
the type of investor that's
participating here are they my guess
would be that they're younger they're
kind of more digitally native they are
attracted as you know these types of
assets etc if I don't have the capital
base to like go buy the Aston Martin or
buy the Ferrari accurate not accurate
act super accurate so to the point that
I think you might be and you might have
access to our talk towards he might have
heard them pitch this one time before so
I have a little bit of an advantage so
it's a we're at a point that we have you
know the users that we have these end
using these investors they're you know
early early 30s late 20s they have
financial education that I did not have
when I was you know 25 years old where
they understand some really complex
strategies but they also know that this
can live next to their crypto
investments and next to their equities
investments in a way that you know
Mickey Mantle has a brand that's you
know 80 years old that everybody really
understands at this point so to say this
has value we didn't have to educate that
much on that part of it we didn't
educate on what happens with your money
so we see is that people come in all
interested they'll buy one or two shares
the wait until they see some trading and
then they'll really put some more money
into the intonational offering so it's
young they're digitally native they're
definitely mobile first they're willing
to take a risk I think on a brand that's
not necessarily the household name but
someone that's doing something
interesting and it's transparent about
it that's what we've always tried to do
from jump and we've seen that we've been
rewarded in that the people that come on
our platform they stick around they ask
questions they're in a way that you know
just our slack channel with our VIP
users who are always giving us feedback
on what we do as a business and what the
feature set should look like and really
driven what the future this platform
looks like so it's been out of all the
consumer platforms I've worked on this
is number this is my third startup I'm
working in consumer this is the most
engaged and the most educated user base
that I've ever worked with and they're
also the most vocal when they see
something they like they let us know and
they see something they don't like they
let us know but now we're starting to
develop it where it's almost like this
big syndicate that tells us exactly what
they want
were able to go source those amazing
assets for them and and is their
functionality today where let's say I'm
like hey I'd love to own a piece of that
Corvette or that Ferrari or whatever and
I can service that idea and then if
enough people get behind it you guys
watch LIGO source it or is that more
kind of informal today yeah I think that
we're doing this right now like you know
no Commission's no management fees it's
completely free and you just touched on
what will potentially be one of like the
subscription models words if you have
you know six people that all want to put
this money and have the syndicate you
want to auto deploy capital to something
specific you can't find will get that
for you so we have a lot of feedback
that from from sellers of assets right
now will they'll come in and say like I
have these three or four things I think
are really interesting I don't want to
go the auction route would you guys be
interested in doing this and we always
have those conversation has to have
those conversations non-stop but we've
seen the other side developed now to
where it's a group of you know five or
six people where one friend is like the
apex of their friend group and they
invested on rally road super early and
then they put it in their group chat the
same way happen with crypto words like
as always that one person in the retail
group that says like guys you should put
your money here and we're seeing those
sort of pockets dr. developer 10 or 12
friends that want something really
specific and they'll come tell us and
we're able to kind of put that into sort
of the into the asset acquisition funnel
and make sure we can get them something
awesome mm-hmm absolutely
and I guess really the the key here for
you guys is if you keep that customer
happy or that investor happy with the
assets that you provide the user
experience you provide all of the kind
of transparent information before they
make a decision all of that stuff goes
to kind of having a defendable moat
really right if you keep them pleased
and you keep them excited about what you
guys are doing just keep serving them
value and that's where you kind of take
the business yeah and the value for us
is in more unique interesting cool [ __ ]
to be honest and more of these things
that that activate this user base where
they care about what we're doing so it's
the craziest thing you guys looked at uh
we even get Steve Jobs sl55 so Steve
Jobs had this thing where he would do he
hated he did want to have anyone know
his plates so he every six months would
get in new Mercedes and he would have
the paper tags on and tear them down and
like [ __ ] sideways in the handicap spots
and he was just reckless with these cars
but the first one that he ever leased he
always did these six month leases was
about to go to auction and the
owner ping dusters like you guys want it
and we were like to him should we do
this but it was really early in the
business we weren't sure that it was
gonna be something that resonated with
users so we held off on it
but we see really weird stuff some of
the books - that's pretty cool that we
have so much cool stuff that we get
access to but some of it is like how do
we wrap a story around this if we can't
wrap the perfect story around for our
investors so if they haven't asked for
it it's something that we usually put to
the side for the time being got it
what is the thing that was the weirdest
so like that was crazy because it was
cool yeah what's the weirdest thing we
were just like I can't believe someone
asked us if we would put this on our
plans we got a lot of weird people who
send that they'll send and they're
awesome because they're brought if I'm
flat from I came and saw crazy but
they'll send us these really cryptic
messages like we should mean to parking
lots I've stuff about what they have and
I'll wind up being like a sword or it'll
be like some random oh so there's
something that they do it's cool to
someone and it's I don't know we don't
know if it's cool for everyone our whole
thing is like rallying people together
to do something sick like that they
really care about it's always some weird
stuff I gotta look through the the
archives to this but there's been like
um there's been there's been like the
skulls and stuff like that where it's
like I'm not so sure there's been some
stuff that from like shipwrecks and a
lot of weird thing it's really it's
really hard to authenticate it and it's
hard to sort of wrap our heads around
how that story's gonna be told so we put
it to the side we never say no we always
put into the bucket of like we should
get back to these people you know we'll
have the first conversation with
something too creepy or if it's
something that is gonna be a little bit
too polarizing or if it's something we
have to meet in the dark parking lot we
usually say no the first time for sure I
love it
what are you most excited about in terms
of like where you guys can go right so
you've built this product already you
it's obviously working like when you
look out 10 years from now what will get
you excited yeah we're excited about and
me personally about the intangible so
like I came from music and to me that's
an industry that the music business as a
whole is is doing you know is the music
industry is doing great the business of
music is still in this weird inflection
period so getting to intangible assets
similar what like Spencer Dinwiddie is
doing and some of these people who are
really thinking about themselves as a
piece of a bigger thing and being able
to sort of set the price on their own
Worth and their own equity and do it in
a way that it's not circumventing the
powers that be but it's taking out a
service layer that lives in between fans
and the things they care about
so the way that we think about the
future is you know these cash producing
assets that aren't something we have to
create dividends around it's something
that really has the chance to skyrocket
in value and have you be a part of it
early it's the idea that right now I
could say you know I saw this band super
early it was you know I saw I saw the
Rolling Stones when it was a small like
it's like 70 80 year olds like I saw the
wrong someone's I read a random bar in
London my dad grew up in in New Jersey
and he said that the big thing to do
which which speaks to his age was a good
Asbury Park yeah and and race around
right and they're all into cars all
stuff yeah and he says that one of the
the biggest memories as a kid was when
Bruce Springsteen kind of a jukebox
y-yo the dude from New Jersey bucks
people tell that story and like it turns
from three people that were there to
like 100 yeah the Woodstock stories
everyone says they were at Woodstock
like if everybody it's something right
what stock was actually there there's
been a hundred million people but it's
also like there are people who get it
early and they want to get behind
somebody's career or get behind
somebody's idea and they want to do it
in a way where it's putting their money
where their mouth is for real instead of
just texting people like ten years later
yeah so that been when there was nobody
in the room it's like no I actually
didn't I invested in that person's
career and now I'm up you know twelve
thousand percent on it because I was
there early so that's where I think
about the future of what investing looks
like it's really the ability for
somebody to not have to go the route of
the big machine to go completely
independent but in a way where your
superfans have agreed with the price
that you set on what you're doing on
what your idea is what your career looks
like and they're participating along the
way at every step that's always
something that we've looked at as the
end goal for us yeah and to me what's
really interesting about this is you are
almost overly aligning incentives right
if I'm a fan of some music I buy in
let's say that the LLC owns 10% of the
revenue of this band for the next five
years or something I'm gonna go to every
single person in the world listen to
this song on Drive and every part I go
to them I go turn it on streaming cuz
it's just money right that's it and you
really get the buy-in your your
quote-unquote investor now has a
financial incentive to see you be
successful yeah and it really changes
the engagement in the relationship
between that flea that musician whoever
and their fans yeah and it's it's like
that situation that way
you don't need that machine behind you
of the record label or the league or
whatever it is to push that narrative if
people believe in you we've seen it now
like the the way information travels is
the small group can push this really
really enormous thing and that's what
we've always looked at as the end goal
for us it's not a situation that we feel
like you know people need to make a
binary decision we want people to get
out along the way but if you believe in
somebody or believe in something you
know the small seed can plant something
really big for us our goal every time we
add a new feature or do something new
with an asset or launch a new store we
want to make it into the group chat like
that's such an important thing for us
right now is to get into the
conversation with you and your friends
where you're the trusted resource for
information and we're a part of that
conversation so the same thing could
happen with all these intangible assets
for sure what um what when you look out
there what's like the one asset you're
like man if we could get this we'd put
it on the platform immediately there's a
lot of stuff to look at like what send
us Twitter our me to go find it yeah I
mean that would be one of those
situation where like we get a piece of
Mars type of stuff like that's really
crazy that hasn't really become a thing
yet that's why I start to look at like
this one all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
pitch you cuz you said Mars there there
is a that there's a Tom DeLonge or
whatever right from up liquidates he's
got this whole alien yeah he really
believes it but then a lot of people who
listen to podcast have also heard Bob
Lazar right yeah I'm sorry talk to also
and one of the things that I think would
be super cool weather for your platform
are just in general own is there's these
pieces of material that have different
scientific characteristics that you know
quantum physics except they just can't
explain it yeah and and to me it's like
the fact that that's sitting somewhere
like a lab is it's pretty crazy because
no one really knows what's going on yeah
and I my guess is that they eventually
end up in a museum somewhere dude you're
speaking our language I think about that
all the time like when I was younger
there was like the little mini museum
thing there's all these pieces it was
like every elements of the periodic
table and every weird Rock and there's
all these little pieces of it I was like
this thousand dollar thing at like
Spencer Gifts of those weird mall stores
and I always look at that's like the
Grail like I wanted to I wanted to save
all of my like paper route money to go
buy that thing but that's the stuff that
gets me super excited where you don't
know what you don't even knows what the
value actually is of what its gonna be
or what it even is if we can do more
stuff like that and really do true IPOs
where you let the crowd set the price on
it and that is
super interesting to us for sure yeah
and to me the the part that makes that
stuff interesting is one this story
right would you keep kind of hammering
on but also it it pulls in people
through like a curiosity element right
of you know the Mickey Mantle story okay
I got it but like when you say hey it's
worth $130,000 or whatever like wait
what yeah what that's sticker price that
shock value a little bit as has driven
some of the best conversations yeah I
mean I might need to go in the shoe box
to see what other car yeah yeah I mean
we want to sort of have people run to
their parents attic and look for stuff
you know that's that's what I did that's
the thing that when I started looking
around her so thinking like why I'm
having all these conversations and I'm
getting these weird nostalgic moments
and I start thinking like oh man I think
I had that baseball Carter I had that
yeah I go check but it works the other
way too where you know we had this
really unique one up to Lamborghini
inside the store this Lamborghini
Countach maybe three months ago and it
was one that even Lamborghini thought
was lost forever on the Wikipedia page
for Lamborghini now it says home by
rally Road the investors but it used to
say they're not sure if it ever existed
this Lamborghini Countach turbo because
there's no record of it what I found the
original sort of manufacturer we found
that the the guy whose source it for us
so in a picture in the back of a room
somewhere so it was just this thing and
that tells us great story we put in the
middle of the store it was valued at
$635,000 but everybody walked in they go
that's a million-dollar car so it's like
that weird disconnect between value
price yeah optics you know yeah
something that well usually begin to
existence with a car like that yeah and
then that story no another go this has
to be worth millions of dollars and
we're like not actually it's only worth
635 right now the chance for to get
there is there but if you hear this
story about this vehicle you can
understand why it might actually make it
to that point yeah yeah it's um it
really is pretty cool I have a growing
up I had a rookie card for a Frank
Thomas Thomas rookies and that's like
this started you'll love this story is a
so I I had a shoebox and my parachute
abayas you know baseball cards basically
like I hey don't go do stupid stuff go
ahead it's right and I remember had this
rookie card
for Frank Thomas and I went to one of
these kind of like a flea market type
thing and somebody there was into
baseball cards and so I remember walking
up to him being like oh I got this card
at home like what do you think it's
worth
I don't know the price but that thing's
really valuable it's awesome so I get my
hopes and dreams up right I went to the
store and I had my parents buy me like
never the little paper magazine or
whatever I was like ten dollars right
cuz there was so many of them printed
like also but I remember like that whole
experience
you guys are essentially providing that
today for people in the digitally native
work I mean you must have heard one of
these entries I did a long time ago as I
said like one of the reason that we
started this company was that Frank
Thomas rookie card real dead serious I
was in so I'm born in Brooklyn but the
place that we would always go like there
was a in a shtetl a mall was a card
stand and I remember when that car came
out it was such a big deal for some
reason I have no idea why cuz cellphones
did not exist yet I was talking about it
and we went to these set on the mall and
I spent it was like four I think was 40
bucks and I bought it and it was like
every dollar I had 40 or 1300 so you
went you bought the specific car yeah I
bought that I got I was trying to buy
was buying like boxes and I couldn't get
one so I was like I already spent I
gotta commit I gotta go buy it so I
bought it and I'm looking at it though I
kept that forever I still have it in my
parents house somewhere and it was such
a big deal it was such a big deal for
some reason which is insane because why
would anyone from the White Sox matter
to somebody in New York I don't remember
why yeah it's such a big I actually
don't want to admit this I'm gonna tell
you which means I might end up telling
people my parents knew that it was such
a big deal for me that they bought like
instead of a picture frame there was
like these card frames yeah yeah the
card in its like it has the the back
part to actually help it stand up yeah
I had that in my room so I was like 16
years old can I remember one day my
brother walked in and my brother was
like yeah oh you're weird but the same
thing was happening in New York dude I
probably had the exact same stand just
by the exact same time we're probably
staring at it that's awesome
all right uh before I wrap up I was
asked some rapid-fire questions what's
the one regulation that you would change
your improve if you could I think the
man this is that this is like god this
is a loaded question I think a lot of
the way that reg D is structured and
what an accredited investor means I
think it will be rethought at some point
soon I think just say the the benchmark
is so high but prevents a lot of really
unique offerings and unique investors
from being a part of really cool stuff
god
what's the most important book you've
ever read man that's good I think like I
only ask good questions man yeah I used
is this one I say this a lot I talk
about it in the office lap with the
nudge unit which is a nudge unit yeah
it's really unique marketing books about
this team in the UK this team of
researchers who their whole goal was to
sort of make big splashes with small
groups and it started with a story I'm
gonna butcher this story
yeah what about about taxes in the UK
and they found that there was only a
small percentage people hadn't pay their
taxes but it was a big chunk of money so
they were sending out letters to almost
at a micro level two people on
individual streets and everybody would
get the letter and it said and it said
85% of your street has paid their taxes
this year or something to that effect
and they got the conversion of people
who didn't pay their taxes just knowing
they're on the outside of that group it
spiked dramatically and that turned into
this whole unit of this whole group of
scientists and sort of economists who
thought about ways to sort of make big
changes with small pieces and that's
something I've reread a lot yeah that's
actually really cool yeah I've not read
that sauce or read it but then is that
there's other like the in school type
stuff like that shaped me like the Great
Gatsby tough stuff that you're required
to read elective grade that definitely
shaped a lot of my thoughts about the
future I've talked on the podcast before
but I actually have never I can't think
of a single book in high school that we
were supposed to read that I actually
read like this yeah I just read the
cliff notes though right and they would
go any bigger I think I got it we're on
the same page the cliff notes were out
that was a thing like you couldn't have
them be seen in your backpack type stuff
you know super not allowed right that
also lets like a lot of cut like I only
like I've read nothing Gladwell books in
college and I mean like there's a lot of
really stuff that is looked at it's sort
of more pop culture stuff and real real
literary sort of figures look maybe look
at a little bit differently it's for the
masses but that stuff that always that
was like the first it was more
interesting more interesting yeah the
book I remember that they were there's
two books Fahrenheit 451 and Dante's
Inferno and they were like bashing it
over our heads out like you I do not
want to reread a 400 pages right 15
years old you're like let me and
all right we talked a little bit about
it aliens believer non-believer
I think I think it's it so be ignorant
to think that we're the only people in
this and then we're a small speck in a
small galaxy to think that this exact
dynamic doesn't exist of Suns moons life
in somewhere else is insane I'm banning
this answer this is the most popular
answer I'm gonna say this loud to you
yeah because everyone says that it's
it's like selfish of us to think no
question right but the part that I keep
coming back to here is so I'm bringing a
guy on the podcast this will go out
before he comes on he claims that 780
thousand years ago there was a I'm gonna
butcher but a post biological
extraterrestrial artificial intelligence
alien craft blew up your earth and all
of this like materials and stuff that
now people are showing up with come from
this explosion anything's possible that
being said if you have to add that many
words to one noun it never usually is
true he's DMM me on Twitter and I said
hey bro hold on pause and I had to go
google post biological that being said
who might say it's wrong I have no idea
anyone knows read 70,000 years ago so I
have no idea I mean crazy stuff all
right what one question do you have for
me to finish up man what and when you
get when some like today like a
precipitous drop in bit what people look
at this and as the bottom and they know
what's happening it's happening again
when you get those phone calls what's
the first thing that you think when you
have to answer a question of wasa all
right so the context here is that we're
recording on a day that Bitcoin just
dropped about 8 percent or so suck is
going to testify in front of Congress
and the futures are expiring in a couple
of days and so short answer is nobody
knows why right I mean there's what
there's a bunch of things that kind of
add up to why but when people call to
things go through my head one is 95
percent of those people don't care
except for there's a 10% movement in
either direction right so with a big
drop big rise so it's funny to me to see
like who the people are and the second
thing that that jumps on my mind is
they're looking at this such short term
right I look at it as it's very similar
to venture investment right in the sense
of it either works or it doesn't and
that's a very binary outcome and so the
the price movements like all this stuff
is tied to that binary outcome and so
it's like yeah you could look and I
could call you every day and be like all
what happened today we're not 5 percent
went down 2% this is it you and I'll get
really really annoyed and have a
headache by the end of the week right
let alone doing this for like and you
start your day like that so that's it's
it's always good to hear somebody say
like listen nobody knows yeah anyone
that tries in my mind you try and tie a
specific event to any up or down
movement of anything you're just
reaching it's such a reach unless
there's really a very very binary reason
so they get to hear a neck what I
consider an expert in space say there
are times where it's like you don't when
people will not know is almost
comforting well not really my portfolio
okay so so one definite not an expert
but two let's look at the public equity
markets right so here's the corollary if
I said to you X company is gonna report
earnings and they're going to beat
expectations and they're going to
increase their future outlook you would
say Wow socks gonna rally right but not
necessary but there's a lot of times
where it does it yeah because I mean
something else
and you're talking about like every
indicator for the future they're basing
on the past so I think about like a cnpc
I get comfort in like in pop going on
CNBC put on your blue suit the outfit
and going on TV I'm more comfortable
seeing new someone I know has a true
opinion on something isn't trying to
connect dots telling me something about
potentially about the future I feel way
better badder than having to try and
connect dots on CNBC I'm gonna have to
start selling the time and it's the only
way I'm gonna IPO it on Raleigh Road
damn looks like I think we have a lot of
interested investors who get behind that
all right man listen we'll have to do
this again I appreciate you coming on
likewise man hey everyone pop here if
you like this episode of off the chain
and want to help us take crypto to the
top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain homepage
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars
taking 15 seconds to fill those stars in
and leave
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain